[Music]
welcome to best practices for privacy
and security in GCE my name is Surrey I
am a product manager on the compute
engine team I am engineer and I'm ready
for a 400 level talk on the theory of
securitrons okay you're gonna have to
wait just a little bit because this is
the 200 level talk but we still have a
lot of great content for you today so I
wanted to get started so over the past
years we've learned a lot here at Google
cloud in securing both our internal
cloud and the clouds for our customers
and the goal of the next 50 minutes is
for us to share some of those learnings
for you to share some of the best
practices we picked up so that you don't
have to make the same mistakes that we
did and that we you know you can take
off running when it comes to securing
your cloud so often when we talk to
customers they'll ask us a question that
sounds something like this they'll say
hey how do I check off that security box
how do I make sure my cloud is
completely completely secure and to that
we say well that's a good question
and cache and I got in a room we thought
about it for a little bit and it turns
out it's the craziest thing you can
actually see clear secure your cloud
with just this one weird trick it's
pretty crazy
are you ready for it just kidding that's
not a thing it'd be crazy wouldn't that
be crazy though like this whole talk
could be over in like two minutes in
reality what we found in over the past
years is that security is a lot more of
a dynamic contextual thing so if you
think about it in terms of securing a
physical space like securing Moscone
Center the correct level of security or
the correct security posture from
Moscone Center is gonna depend on a
number of factors right it's gonna
depend on what part of Moscone you're
trying to secure are you trying to
secure the front sidewalk are you trying
to secure the generator room right it
also is going to depend on what's
happening a Musco knee center is you
know is this an open house steady one
can attend or is this it was a president
in town giving a speech right and
there's and even more if you are in
charge of the team that's securing
Moscone Center is your responsibility to
just secure this building or is it to
secure the entire complex or is it to
secure a nationwide chain of convention
centers right that's all gonna be a
different part of the
calculation of the equation and it's
going to change how you approach
security right and so when you look at
security posture first of all it lies on
a spectrum regardless of what you're
trying to secure it lies on a spectrum
and we should recognize that it can be
too loose no matter what you're trying
to secure it can be too loose it can be
the Wild West anyone could do anything
and for sure bad things are gonna happen
there but it can also be too strict
right you can have too many rules too
many things lock down and that's bad too
because that'll lead to loss of agility
it might lead to antagonistic
relationship between your security teams
and everyone else and a number of other
things and so to start the talk I want
to set aside some principles to help you
try to understand and navigate the
spectrum and get to the right spot there
so the first principle I want to talk
about is centralized administration and
this is the idea that if you as a
central security team there should be a
central security team that has full
awareness of everything that's going on
or at least the ability to be fully
aware of what's going on and also has
responsibilities and governance and
authority to govern over everything
that's going on right centralized
governance without that if you don't
know if you don't have the ability to
know it's what all is going on or the
authority to enforce what's going on
you're almost certainly too loose but if
you just have what we found this if you
just have centralized administration you
may end up falling on the opposite end
of the spectrum especially in a larger
organization if you have a team of
hundreds or thousands and the
responsibility for securing and tracking
down everything that's happening is
falling on the shoulders of very few
people you may end up on the opposite
side of the spectrum where you're forced
to lock down everything or you're forced
to implement policies that you can't
keep track of because there's just so
much going on and so to that we
introduce a second principle called
delegation this is the idea that if you
have a centralized administrative team
that they can still delegate
administrative tasks to a separate sub
team or some other division or some
other set of folks and that they can
move much quicker
having delegated authority and what we
found is that between those two
principles you're able to get closer to
the center and get into what we call the
the Goldilocks zone it's a technical
term where you basically have the right
mix of two too loose and too strict
and notice what we've done here is we've
called it a zone this is not as a
Goldilocks point and that's in
recognition that your security posture
the right place to pick on the security
posture is going to be very context
really relevant it's going to depend on
the context for your cloud just as it
depended on the context for Moscone
Center and so what we're gonna do within
this presentation is we're gonna start
with the building blocks for security
start with some of the tools there and
we're gonna build our way up to some
best practices that we've learned but
when we but by doing so will allow you
to kind of pick up the best practices
some of what you should do regardless
like all the time but some of which will
depend the practice of some of which
will depend on what your security
context is and what's the right security
posture for your organization
ok so the first building block starting
simple are the identities right this is
the set of users and groups and services
that you have that Google Cloud knows
about Google cloud knows about them
because Google Cloud identity which is
our identity service knows about them
now we understand the quick thing I'll
say here is that we understand that some
of you may have your identities mastered
elsewhere in fact that might be most of
you right a lot of organizations that we
talk to they master the identities in
Active Directory and I just want to call
out that it is possible we do support
you syncing your identities from
wherever you master them into Google
cloud identity so that you can keep
mastering them wherever they currently
exist next I want to talk about
resources so these are the things that
you're ultimately trying to protect when
it comes to compute engine these might
be your VMs and your disks and your
subnets and your images but resources
also apply to any non Google compute
engine resources inside GCP as well
resources of course roll up to one and
only one project these are our base
level of grouping and so all resources
have to belong to one project and
projects also encapsulate some other
properties like the billing account
quotas permissions and things like that
the next level up is the organization so
this is an optional concept you don't
have to have an organization but we
highly highly encourage it for reasons
that I'll get into you for a second but
these will act as the root node for all
GCP resources so everything if you set
up an organization
everything should roll up into the
organization and finally we have folders
these are an additional optional
grouping mechanism they can contain
other projects or folders and we found
that this is a great way to organize and
make sense of your policy your policies
so we're gonna dive a little bit more
abstract in a sec so bear with me but
will then make it more concrete with
some examples and some best practices to
put them together so once you have the
resource hierarchy in place you can
apply policies to this resource
hierarchy policies can be applied
anywhere in the resource hierarchy and
once they're applied a policy is then
passed from the parent to the child so
for example if I set a policy on
Department X it'll pass down to all the
other subfolders under Department X as
the folder that'll get passed down into
the projects and into the resources into
the resources there we go there are two
types of policies one is called the
first one is called iam policies so
these are in the business of granting
permissions to particular identities for
particular resources the second type is
called organization policies these are
in the business of creating constraints
let's talk about iam policies first I am
policies control who is allowed to do
what on which resources so it takes a
set of identities like a user or a group
or a service account and then it takes a
set of resources like a folder or a
project or individual resources and it
says these identities will have these
permissions on these resources and it
does that by setting by through a
particular role so in this particular
example we might give for example Alice
the compute instance admin role on an
individual VM and what that'll do is
it'll give Alice permissions to do
instance administrative actions on that
VM like creating VMs or like creating it
well it's already created deleting it
starting it or stopping it so what I
find is that it helps make things a
little more concrete if we show what
this looks like in the UI you can of
course set permissions ng cloud in the
api's as well but for the purposes of
this presentation we'll go in the UI so
here I'm in the instances list in
compute engine
I can select a particular VM here I've
selected instance 1000
and now that I've specified the resource
I just need to say who can do what on
that resource right and so if I click
the add members button over in the top
right there I can answer those two
questions so it will ask me who do you
want to have this policy and also what
role do you want do you want to apply to
this user so in this particular case I'm
gonna give Alice this particular role
and the role I'm going to give is the
instance administrator role so that's
just walking through what the previous
example concretely look like next the
second type of policy is called the
organizational policy so these are in
the business of placing restrictions on
your resources and some examples of that
are you might want to restrict the
specific types of api's or specific set
of services that can be used in a
particular folder or project you might
want to restrict the set of VMs that
have external IPS or the third example
there is you might want to restrict a
set of users that can be added to I M
policies concretely what this looks like
is if you go into a project or a folder
or an organization and you go into the
iam section and then the org policy
subsection you can see the full list of
organizational policies that we support
and the important thing here is you know
we offer a lot of them we offer more all
we're adding to that list all the time
and so one thing we recommend is just
when you're starting your clouds
appointment or even if you've already
got going if you haven't looked through
all of these just take a look it's kind
of like flipping through your iPhone
settings when you first set it up right
here's a concrete example of that so
suppose I'm an administrator and I want
to do my job well and I want to part of
that is preventing data exfiltration
so one org policy that we find is very
effective in helping to do that is the
domain restricted sharing org policy so
what I can use this for is I can dictate
that my developers they're not able to
share resources to users outside of my
organization unless I give them explicit
access to do though to do so similarly
another another vector for data
exfiltration might be external attacks
that go and look for VMs in my
organization with external IP addresses
and so another organization a policy
that I can set is one that restricts the
set of VM instances in my organization
to just
the set of VM instances in my
organization with external IP addresses
and so I will have knowledge about all
of the VMS that are in my organization
that have external IPS okay so let's put
this all together
here's we're back to the hierarchy
resources inherit the policies that we
just talked about from their parent and
so we can see how we can start to apply
some of the principles that we talked
about before so the first principle I
talked about was centralized
administration right you need to give a
way for some central administrative team
to understand what all is going on and
to have some broad authority over that
so what you can do for example is you
can have an IM policy which gives the
compute viewer role this is view only
access to compute resources to your
organizational admin group and then once
you apply that policy to the
organization node you'll see that it
flows down to all the folders and
projects and resources within that node
automatically and this will apply to all
the present resources in your
organization but it'll also apply to all
the future resources in your
organization as well and so you can
start to see how this gives you a bit of
an easier time in doing centralized
administration because you can imagine
if you didn't have this organization
node you might be chasing after
thousands of projects they get spun up
in your organization secondly we can
achieve the second principle as well
which is that of delegation so if you
imagine you have team a over here team a
has an SRE team and as a centralized
administrative group you want to
delegate instance administration actions
to that particular team and you so you
can set the policy on team a's folder to
give instance admin role to the entire
team asre group and that will also
propagate down to all the projects and
resources under team a and so now you've
effectively delegated permissions for
that particular team for that particular
group the same thing applies with org
policies right so suppose I have a
folder and in that folder is supposed to
categorize a set of workloads that are
internal only I don't want these
workloads to ever have an external IP
address which I'm showing here as the
internal folder I can set a org policy
on that particular folder which
restricts all VMs with external
P addresses and in doing so I'll find
that the org policy automatically flows
down to all the resources and projects
in that particular folder and so here
again I have a much easier time of
governing my organization okay
so that was some of the building blocks
I'm going to turn it over to cash who's
gonna start building them up into best
practices Thanks now as you might expect
we talk to a lot of customers day in and
day out this is all we do
we try to help them understand what
where they're coming from and how to
apply the security tools that we're
developing to best solve their security
problems and manage their their cloud
and one of the common problems that we
have and we find that customers have is
that they don't know how to most
effectively apply the organizational
policy or I'm sorry the the resource
hierarchy to organize the resources in
our cloud we find that customers will
sometimes not really know what to do and
they'll end up with the sprawl of
hundreds or thousands of projects all of
which have different policies and
settings and so forth and where they
have to manage each of these
individually likewise other companies
think that maybe the best thing to do is
to take their org chart and sort of push
it into the folder structure and use
that and we find that the best
hierarchies don't do either of those and
instead they sort of build off of two
concepts the first concept is delegating
of authorities Siri mentioned and the
second is grouping resources of like
risk together where you can apply
similar security policies to the same
sets of resources to show you what that
looks like
here's a simple organization here a
simple company let's decided to build a
couple of applications inside of Google
cloud app one and app two in order to
provide delegated authority they created
folders to represent each of their
applications and underneath the
applications and this is a
representation of delegating authority
to those teams they granted the service
teams that manage app 1 and app to
access to those folders below the
folders there are separate projects each
of them indicating whether the resources
within ur develop our pre-production
development environment resources or
whether
their production resources with critical
data and then this is a saint's grouping
resources in accordance to their their
security profiles security risk the pre
prod environments don't need to be
locked down super hard all the
developers can have access to deploy
code access data whatever they need to
debug and develop their system the
production environment on the other hand
is going to be locked down much more
tightly it only the on colors are going
to have access to fiddle with these
projects and their production systems
are going to be the responsible for
pushing code and data to the assistant
to these environments once the
applications scale is large enough you
can imagine continuing to break down or
apply the hierarchy to break down the
application and manage the complexity
they're in here for instance the
application to has broken itself into
two sub components a front end and a
back end for instance and the
administrators of application two were
responsible delegating Authority so the
front end team in the back-end team to
manage those projects independently and
they were able to set those things up
without having to come back to the
administrator to have to have to
configure it now to look at a more
complicated example using both I in
policy and organization policy you can
do some pretty cool things so here we
have a large organization fairly
complicated there numerous teams
numerous organization and you must
applications within their hundreds of
projects potentially thousands as a
security administrator this makes me
nervous they're all deploying virtual
machines I have no idea what they're
deploying I want to make sure that my
company is making sure that the only
things that are running inside those VMs
are trusted code I need to put down an
operating system standard I need to make
sure that it's running all the Damons
all the logging all the security
protection infrastructure that I need
into those operating systems and I need
to make sure that all developers inside
my organization are using those images
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
hire an image team I probably have one
already I'm going to pull off a section
of my policy hierarchy and I'm going to
grant access to my image team to manage
those images they're going to create
some images test them vet them and then
they're going to publish them to this
project and share those resources with
the rest of my organization
now I can apply an organizational policy
called trusted image projects to the
rest of my organization to lock down and
make sure that the only operating
systems the only boot disks that can be
used in my computer games are created
and pushed by the golden images project
and this allows me to have faith and
confidence in the software that's
running in my cloud I'll wait for a
photo so now that we have a policy here
key the next big question that a lot of
customers have is how do I figure out
how to assign the roles to my employees
and my services and grant access now
this is a hard problem this is
fundamentally the most difficult part of
managing access control and such and
security in a large system you need to
essentially have someone who's capable
of making sense of the system and
granting access that's appropriate for a
business requirement to the service or
the user that's getting such access I
can't just make that problem go away
I'm sorry but we can help you a little
bit we can help you build this build a
set of a set of standards for deploying
access grants that make sense for you so
as you come to cloud to Google cloud
you've probably encountered what we call
the primitive roles called owner editor
and viewer and these come out of the box
they're extremely broad a grants of
access we don't recommend using them for
anything that's a production system
they're there only to get you started
and to help you kick the tires
essentially and the reason that they're
not recommended is because they don't
satisfy what we call the principle of
least privilege we're in the you grant
an axis that's commiserate with the
minimum requirements for each employee
and service in your system now when
you're designing roles it's important to
remember again that you don't want to
specifically identify every single
permission and every single object that
a employee is going to have to access in
general we find there's like a
Goldilocks zone where you were going to
grant a reasonable level access that
contains all the sets of things that are
in line with the business requirements
of the user know that the engineer or
the service that you're deploying you
don't want to be too strict and you
don't want to
now 9 out of 10 security engineers love
our predefined rules to achieve this
purpose the are designed by Google
engineers and PMS based on feedback
we've gotten from all of our customers
their representative the kinds of roles
and segregations of access and
responsibilities that are that that our
customers have been asking for
they've been applying to their own
resources and so for instance here you
can see compute has provided you with a
number of roles such as instant amid
Network admin and load balancer have
been because these are roles that are
naturally managed by separate
individuals in a large number of
organizations the network administrator
is responsible for making sure that the
fire also locked down and so forth and
so on whereas the instance min is
responsible for making sure that the
Hadoop cluster is up and running for
instance now that final security
engineer who wasn't happy enough with
the predefined rules is usually
satisfied and made happy with our custom
roles they're used in special
circumstances where the predefined roles
don't line up exactly with your business
requirements for instance we find that a
lot of customers will combine a number
of predefined roles into a single role a
custom role so that they can grant it
more easily and make sure that all sets
of accesses are present on any resource
which they grant this access another
common pattern is that a security
engineer C is a predefined role that
exactly matches their requirements but
there's that one weird permission inside
that they really don't want them so they
want to take that away from their
engineers now when you're granting
access and assigning roles to your
employees and services it's quite easy
to figure out when you've gotten it
wrong and you've under provisioned the
the access to your resources the
engineers and the service are going to
complain in one way or another and
you're gonna get a ticket or something
to fix the fix the assignments of
authority fix the grants but if you've
over provisioned you don't get any
notice no one comes along and tells you
I have too much power I'm so sorry could
you take some away
I'm happy to let you know that we're
rolling out tools that are that are
going to help you address these kinds of
problems one is for instance called the
roll
I am roll recommender which looks at the
access patterns of users and services in
your system in your cloud and gives you
a historical recommend based on
historical traffic gives you a future
prediction of what the what kinds of
rules you might want to instead given to
the user and this allows you to make
more fine-grain access control and apply
the principle of this privilege in your
cloud at scale so now another kind of
problem that we see and it happens to
everyone it happens to us it happens to
me it happens to our customers they
often will get into a situation in which
they'll find a policy that looks like
this and it's hard to make sense of why
this policy looks the way it looks here
you can see a number of engineers have
different levels of access to this
project I have no idea why any of these
roles exist some companies have
constructed spreadsheets to try to keep
track of the historical reasons about
why every one of these grants has been
created that's one strategy the strategy
we recommend instead is to use what we
call a security group based model which
sort of models the are back ma
philosophy instead of renting roles to
users individually in an ad hoc way what
we recommend is you create security
groups that represent the conceptual
roles and responsibilities each engineer
might have to a resource here for
instance team grilled-cheese has been
broken down into data scientists
debuggers and on collars now I can grant
the access to that project to each of
these roles and responsibilities based
on what they should have access to data
scientists get to run through the
prediction engine the buggers get to run
some queries and access some other data
and on callers get to do everything they
want yeah and then I can independently
manage the sets of users and services
that are members of the security groups
and then I can audit each of these these
category is independently it's often
usually much easier to understand
whether cash belongs to team
grilled-cheese then it
is to decide whether he had think he
should have Auto ml predictor on some
random project in your organization
before I go on from role construction in
rural assignment I'd like to talk about
one other pattern that we've been seeing
a lot of benefits from that's break
glass access so one of the common
failure modes that organizations and
both inside of Google and outside of
Google encounter with Google cloud is
that senior engineers and on-call
engineers end up getting lots of
privileges on a on production resources
often though they're an owner or often
they have administrator rights and they
carry this is what we call ambient
Authority what this means is that it's
quite easy for an on caller to
accidentally visit the wrong project for
instance and do something destructive to
that project thinking they might have
been working on another project this is
not a great situation especially when
your business is on the line what we
recommend instead is creating some sort
of break glass pattern for this kind of
access for a privileged access and in
one way you can do this is with a manual
with I am roles directly or predefined I
am roles such as a project I am admin
project I am in admittin does not give
you the ability to do anything on a
project except for set policy and change
the policy so an on caller instead of
wandering over to the cloud console and
deleting some vm's they have to
contemplative lis first grant themselves
access to delete a VN and then go and
delete a VM we find that the great glass
pattern is actually enhanced and made a
lot more secure by application of
automation and you can use automation
such as Jenkins terraform claude
functions anything that you have
in-house to facilitate both the breaking
of the glass possibly with a ticketing
system or or even an audit and review
process to make sure that the escalation
of privileges was appropriate and then
also to repair the glass to take away
the access when the incidents are
resolved now now that we've dealt with
roles let's deal with securely accessing
my cloud my VMs so securely accessing
data from to and from IBM's involves
three
categories of access the first thing I
need to do is I need to be able to SSH
into and connect to my VMs and figure
out what's going on sometimes second I
need to be able to get securely from my
VMs were closing my VM to needs to
securely get to Google API is to access
storage and and and workflow engines and
all the other products that we offer and
finally your VMs will need to phone home
and make calls to your on-prem services
or to other VMs or to VMs running in
other clouds and do so securely I'm
going to go through each of those in
turn here but before I get Sara oh wait
did you feel that soon it was like a
disturbance as if a thousand of million
credentials were just created and
suddenly silenced because they were
published to a github repository in the
cloud Oh
fix my heart this is what we want you to
avoid in particular unmanaged
credentials is one of the greatest
security threats that we see in in
almost all cloud activity when we work
with our customers we strongly encourage
you to use fully managed credentials in
every circumstance that you can where
the platform takes care of rotating
credentials managing they're keeping
them in escrow and protecting those
credentials from from loss or leakage or
publishing to a repository in the sky
and so to do this first let's look at
the SSH into my VM scenario I just
deployed a 10,000 VM cluster it was
doing something cool trust me but five
of those VMs stopped working and I need
my own callers to be able to get into
those games and figure out what was
going wrong so what I do is I one I go
and grant so some service some customers
will go and push some SSH keys around
into those VMs but the downside of that
approach is that when those keys are
lost or leaked or an employee who had
access to a key leaves your company
you're now stuck with a key that's
leaked that a customer than an employee
that left your company might still be
able to SSH into your VMs instead we
like to recommend that our customers use
what we call OS
it's a product in the compute system
which you can enable by when you create
your VMs you can enable it by sending
metadata on your virtual machine you
enable OS logon and enable OS login
two-factor authentication which requires
that your engineers provide a security
key whenever they ssh into a VM and then
you can control access to your virtual
machines using i.m permissions using the
the OS login or the OS edmund login
roles and what and the difference being
whether you let them log in as
themselves or as root users and if you
put this all together you have complete
assurance that all access to that VM is
tied to the user lifecycle when the user
leaves your when someone when my uncle
leaves my company for whatever reason
they don't have the access to the key
that they have doesn't matter anymore
they can take that key and publish it to
github and it still doesn't give them
access to my VMs next we want to talk
about authenticating my PM securely to
my Google API so my Google resources to
achieve this task what we do is what we
call binding a service account to a
virtual machine the first step is to
create a service identity in the Google
Cloud console the second step is to
grant that service identity access to
all the things that I think my workload
needs access to third and finally when
I'm creating the virtual machine I
select which service account I want that
virtual machine to run as every access
that's made with client libraries
running inside of that virtual machine
is authenticate authenticate to cloud as
the service account identity the keys
the long-term keys are held in escrow
and the only things that the sort that
the workload in the virtual machine gets
is short term access token which can be
used to apply to API calls now one of
the common difficulties with using this
feature is something called access
scopes it's a require you it's something
that you're required to select when
using the feature it is a great source
of confusing to customers we find the
default is set to allow default access
which isn't always the easiest to use we
recommend in
said using allow full access to cloud
api's and what we called the cloud
platform scope this ensures that you
have easy access to call api's it's a
tool to effectively make client library
integration simpler and then use ion
permissions and IM roles granted to the
service account as your security feature
now talking about VMS that need to phone
home a lot of times you're going to be
running only part of your workload on
compute and some of it's going to be
running elsewhere what we to prevent is
to address it for a particular problem
if we use the same thing same approach
that we use for calling into Google API
is previously the you create a service
account you attach it to the VM when
you've constructed it the code in the VM
can then get an access token an OID C
access token which is an industry
standard compliant open ID connect token
that can be verified by verifying the
signature in the token with the OIG C
endpoint for Google and the token
contains all the information that you
could ever possibly need to authorize
access to this VM contains the services
identity it contains the project ID the
zone the VN name the creation date
everything you could possibly ever need
again its standards compliant so it
works with every all all open source
o IDC compliant libraries it gives you a
strong proof of identity and again you
don't have to manage credentials so
everyone's safe next I'd like to talk
about other kinds of threats other kinds
of organizational threats to your to
your virtual machine fleet in particular
root kits and boot kits when you have
people who can SSH in or malicious
software that can hack its way in
through the front door you always have a
risk that the software that you run it
that you're running in your VM fleet is
not the software you think it is unless
you have a strategy to make sure that it
is and the approach to solve that what
you can use is a product we call
shielded VMs which just launched a ga it
allows for a trusted chain of boot from
the virtual TPM of the VM to the through
the firm
through the operating system to make
sure that all the operating all the
software running in the operating system
has been vetted and vouched for if you
have a rootkit that installs random
malware into a kernel module in your
operating system will detect it and will
notify you and tell you which VMs have
been hacked in so you can take Remini of
action to use this feature you can go to
the operating the boot disk operating
system images on compute and you can
filter by the the shielded VM provided
operating system images and then when
you create your VM you turn on the
shielded VM up ssin you can notice that
this is an option and so your you might
worry maybe my developers can not create
a shielded VM that's oh I'm sorry and
that's why we recommend that you combine
that with trusted boot proper the
trusted boot pattern that we showed you
before and organizational policies you
can you can apply the same pattern that
we showed you before where you can have
your operating system images being
vetted and curated by your images team
publish to your organization and then
you can apply an organizational policy
to the rest of your organization to both
require that all VMs be created with the
shielded VM feature and also to ensure
that the only ones that are used are the
ones that you've vetted and approved and
again to turn that on you just go to the
organization policy control panel in
your cloud console and turn on shielded
VMs and your trusted prash the image
projects sinks should I go back okay
finally I'd like to talk about setting
up secured secure by default behaviors
for your cloud like I said before where
sometimes in a tough spot because we're
trying to sell a cloud and to sell a
cloud we need to make it easy to use and
also secure the same time to achieve
this oftentimes the defaults will come
out of the box with things easy to use
you'll get the owner permissions when
you create a project so you can don't
have to worry about taking out the
permission model just to deploy a
function we do recommend that you secure
those projects after you
created them especially when their
production resources now to achieve this
what we find is a factory pattern works
wonders and every one of our customers
that cares about security seems to apply
this fall in this mechanism in one way
or another the basic idea is against a
set up a workflow using Jenkins or Tara
for more cloud function or whatever it
is where your employees your developers
can click on a button hosted by you
posted by you that creates the resource
and GCP and then sets up all the
configuration exactly as you need it so
for instance to achieve this and you can
first go to your organization policy
your ion policy there you'll find a
policy grant that enables everyone in
your domain to be able to create a
project you can disable that take that
permission away instead you can grant
that permission to your workflow engines
that are allowed to create vetted secure
projects again you can use Jenkins and
terraform anything you want and for us
some of the some starting points for
thinking about how you'd like to make
your default projects you could for
instance delete the default compute
service account you can neuter its
permissions which start out fairly
honest fairly with fairly broad editor
permissions you can delete the V PC
network that created an online project
and instead connect that project to a
secured shared V PC that you use for an
organize your entire organization or for
sections of your organization you can
attach billing accounts to make sure
that all the cost centering goes to the
right to the right
billing account you can set up audit
logs and billing exports to make sure
that you have full visibility as to
what's going on in those projects when
you when you unleash it to your
developers and again this gives you
centralized governance and control and
guide rails for your developers and it
eliminates all the challenges of making
your developers get easy access rapid
access to a production environment or to
a developer code or to a create a
production environment and with that
I'll hand it over to Siri tell you more
about keeping track of what your
developers are doing thanks guys
so another type of question we get from
customer
a lot is how do i more easily start to
understand everything that's going on to
my organization and this is a key part
of centralized administration because in
the beginning we talked about how you
can extend permissions to your
organization to your org admin team for
example to view everything but that's
not the same thing as being able to look
over that content in an easily in an
easy way and to analyze what all is
going on and so I want to talk start by
talking about some of the tools that we
offer to start giving you that had a
360-degree view of your organization so
the first tool I want to talk about this
has been around for a while our audit
logs and I don't have time to get too
deep into the nuances of audit logs but
I will talk about a few types that are
really helpful for this particular use
case so the first type I want to talk
about our admin activity logs so these
logs are generated whenever an
administrative action is taken on both
the GCE resource but also most other
types of GCP resources so for example if
I had a user named Alice and she created
a VM in a particular project will create
an admin activity log automatically for
you and that'll include what type of VM
it was what time it happened and other
details that give you more visibility
into what exactly what's happening
these audit logs are enabled by default
in all projects and in addition they're
generated in real-time so they really
give you that up-to-date
up-to-the-second and for details about
what all is going on in your
organization a second type of audit log
that's important to know at this point
is the data access audit log so these
talk about data reads and data accesses
these tend to be a little bit more
verbose so they're not turned on by
default you actually have to go and turn
them on yourself but when you do so that
information will start flowing in and so
in the use cases where you're really
interested in knowing even about the
reads we highly suggest that you turn
these on so with that out logs you get
kind of this moment-by-moment
set of events for your entire
organization and release these and we go
to talk customers and they say this is
good but it's difficult sometimes to
understand the precise state of your
world at a particular moment in time if
I just have a set of events Lading
leading up to the
particular moment right and it's
possible to construct that from on it
logs but it gets a gets a little tricky
and so in response to that feedback
we've actually recently recently
released a second tool that we call the
cloud asset inventory and this tool
answers the question of at a particular
moment in time what resources and
policies were there in my organization
in a particular folder or in a
particular project these tools will look
back this tool this particular API will
actually look back in the last five
weeks so it has knowledge of the last
five weeks and so you can ask a question
like hey last last Saturday at 2:00 a.m.
when I had a security incident or
something like that
what were the VMS are running in my
organization and what were the policies
applied on those VMs and so you can
start to do those forensics type
investigations or you can start you know
you can imagine you could use it for any
other number of use cases and it's great
for printing out that state because it
has knowledge of your environment for
the last five weeks it can also tell you
about how a particular resource changed
over the past five weeks so kind of like
a scrubbing overtime you can see how a
VM might have evolved you can see who
gained or lost access to that VM and so
you can think of these as the two
building blocks to get to start getting
an understanding of what's going on in
your organization I won't delve too much
deeper here other than to say that we'll
be going much deeper into this at
tomorrow's session called best practices
for GC Enterprise deployments now having
released both of these tools what we see
a lot of times is that customers will go
through and build very similar solutions
on top of these building blocks they'll
build solutions to go and list out all
of the assets in their organization and
they might also scan the events and the
assets in their organization for things
that they don't want to have happen
right scan for vulnerabilities scan for
that the right set of firewall rules are
set up etc and so in response to that we
wanted to deliver some of that
functionality out of the box and so we
recently released a beta the cloud
security command center this is going to
provide a lot of that functionality out
of the box it's going to be a single
pane of glass that's going to let you
understand what resources are in your
organization let you explore what
resources are in your organization and
also it'll do proactively be scanning
for vulnerabilities and
actively informing you of for example if
you have suspicious traffic going on if
you have vm's with insecure firewalls
and things like that so based on the
feedback we got from what type of
solutions our customers built based on
our building blocks we've built some of
that out of the box for you and if you
want to go further if you want to modify
that or change something based on your
security posture you can always go back
to your building blocks and build that
out from there okay last section this is
on I want to talk a little bit about the
tools that we provide you as our
customers to ensure your privacy and to
ensure that you're in full control over
your data in Google Cloud so one thing
we hear a lot from customers especially
those in more tightly regulated
industries like banking is that they
want control full control over their
data that they upload to the cloud it
might be very sensitive they might be
beholden to regulatory needs to do so
and one way that this translates is most
of the times customers asked for more
control over how their data is encrypted
in the cloud so that they can manage
that encryption and so that they could
for example take away the encryption
keys protecting their data so that no
one has access to that data anymore not
even us Google right so the first thing
I want to talk I want to say before I
proceed is that by default all data in
Google Cloud is secure is encrypted at
risk regardless of configuration so even
if you don't go in if even if you go in
and you don't configure any of this data
any of this encryption will still do it
for you automatically but we do give you
the tools to go further a best practice
that's quickly developing is that
customers can use another managed
service that Google cloud provides
called Google key management service
this is a managed service that allows
you to manage keys so you can create
keys rotate keys delete them at any time
and then you can apply these keys to
your disks to your images and snapshots
and any other content that you store in
GCE and we'll start using that key that
you've managed to go ahead and start
encrypting your data I should also note
that this whole flow is supported with
is integrated with I am and audit
logging so all the tools that we just
talked about so you can see who's doing
the encryption and where these keys are
and cloud kms is also has a broad
support for all of the set of security
standards that we've been hearing our
fired from my customers so what this
looks like you would start by creating a
key in the keyring and cloud kms that's
a very quick task you should just take
you a few minutes and you can specify
what this the rotation period of this
key how what encryption standard it uses
etc and then when you go and create a
GCE disk or image or snapshot you'll
just point GCE to that particular key
that you've just created and just like
that we'll start using that particular
key to protect your data and so what
that means is as needed later you can go
revoke or disable access to that key
this is what it looks like both in the
UI and in the g-cloud command line tool
and from there once you've disabled
access what you'll find is that GCE will
no longer have access to that
information at all so if you try to
attach a disk that's protected by the
revoked key to a VM you'll see that that
action fails and that'll fail until you
restore access to the key and so in this
way you have full control over who has
access to your data on Google Cloud
another question that we get from
customers is well hey your Google how do
I know that you're not using my data for
other means right how do I know you're
not using it to Train some you know
absolute to advertise or something like
that now here I want to say again that
at Google Cloud we do not access your
data for any other reason than those
necessary to fulfill our contractual
obligations to you and in fact if when
we looked at the data internally over 99
percent of when we do these data
accesses they're to fulfill support
requests so it's where customers are
actually asking us to do these to do
these actions but you don't have to take
our word for it we have a feature called
access transparency logs during another
type of audit logs that we just talked
about and what they do is they'll tell
you in near-real-time and without cost
anytime Google accesses your data for
any reason right the one caveat here is
that these are available for only a
certain set a subset of our support
packages and you can find out more
details online but they're very easy to
enable so as long as you have the right
permissions that's step one we have a
particular role for this access
transparency admin you can just go into
a particular
project folder organization and you'll
find a little toggle and I am admin
settings and from there you can go and
you'll just see that wherever however
you're getting your logs maybe it's
through the stack driver logging portal
you'll start seeing these access
transparency locks so what does that
look like here's an example of an access
transparency log it'll be generated once
for every action that we take on your on
your data and it will tell you in yellow
you can see it tells you the reason so
why did we access your data here in
particular we're doing this because of a
customer initiated support request and
we'll attach the case number for you and
then in green you can see what exactly
Google did so you can see the resource
that we were operating on the API calls
that we made when we did this and a
number of other details relevant to the
case and so you don't have to take our
word for what I just said you can
actually go in and verify it yourselves
and so with that that brings us to the
end of our talk hopefully you know we
started by laying down some principles
and hopefully we've been able to build
up to a set of best practices to go
apply those principles thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]